now today for our daily cancellation now
that christmas season has
officially or rather unofficially begun
officially the christmas season actually
starts on christmas i don't know if you
knew that
i'm going to take a bold bold step that
will only shock and offend you until you
realize that i come
not as your oppressor but as your
liberator i seek to free you and free
all of us once and for all
from the tyranny of christmas trees
christmas trees are canceled
this madness has gone on for long enough
i'm drawing the line in the sand right
now
no more christmas trees we are done with
christmas trees
now it may come as a surprise but the
early christians
never thought to cut down a tree and put
it in their house
for three weeks as part of their
christmas celebration
one could only imagine how the
conversation would have went had anyone
suggested something like that
hey it's almost christmas what do you
say we go and chop down that perfectly
healthy tree out there drag it inside
and watch it slowly die
it'll be so festive the idea probably
would not have been warmly received
and that's why nobody had a christmas
tree until some depraved lunatic in
germany
as always in the 19th century decided
that there weren't enough
distracting hassles associated with the
holiday and came up with this
idea and it was the worst thing anyone
had done
related to christmas since saint nick
started the whole gift-giving thing
which is another problem in of itself
now admittedly
this history of christmas and its
traditions may not be entirely
technically accurate but that's not the
point
the point is that we are all burdening
ourselves
with this demented custom for no reason
so there are of course two ways to
approach the problem of obtaining
transporting and erecting
a tree inside your living room this
again is a problem
of our own making it's like if we're all
stressed out
about how to capture a squirrel from the
forest and train it to do jumping jacks
the most stress-free way of doing that
is to not do it
because it's bizarre and pointless and
there are a million better ways to spend
your time
but as far as trees go you have two
options right you can go out and buy a
real tree
or you can purchase an imposter a fake
tree an
avatar of a tree the problem with the
fake tree is that it's a fake tree
it's expensive and clunky it doesn't
actually look anything like a real tree
much less does it smell like one so it's
always awkward when you go to someone's
house
and they have a fake tree and they go
doesn't it look real
no it doesn't have you ever seen a real
tree they're outside you should go check
them out
because this doesn't look anything like
it
see whatever joy there is to be gained
from a christmas tree you aren't going
to get it from a fake one
a family with a fake tree has given up
they are just checking the tree box
trying to slide by on a technicality you
might as well put a deflated basketball
on your porch at halloween instead of a
pumpkin
the stand-in is significantly more
depressing
than just not having it at all so that
doesn't work but the real tree is worse
because first of all it's going to run
you upwards of 75 these days 75
for a hunk of lumber that will be
decaying in a heap on your front lawn in
less than a month
you could buy a bottle of blanton's
single barrel bourbon
elijah craig barrel proof even for that
price and it will make you far
jollier than any christmas tree ever
will i assure you so after you've been
basically stripped naked and robbed by
the christmas tree salesman
you schlepped the thing back to your
house you dragged it inside pine needles
falling and dispersing themselves into
areas of the house that
you won't notice until sometime after
memorial day then begins the process of
somehow
getting this whole entire actual tree to
stand up straight in your house with
nothing but a plastic tree stand and a
couple of screws keeping it in place
if you do get it the same place it'll
inevitably be knocked over multiple
times by the dog the cat your kids
people and pets getting practically
crushed to death left and right
meanwhile the thing requires about 19
gallons of water a day just to keep it
alive and barely so
now you have a half dead dried out chunk
of wood in your house
with electrical wires draped around it
maybe next we can develop an easter
tradition where everybody jumps into a
pool and plays catch with a toaster
plugged into an extension cord
and then what happens as soon as
christmas is over it's like waking up
with a hangover you
look at that thing and all of the joy
and spirit is
sucked out of it now you see it for the
giant pile of sticks that it always was
and you just want it out of your house
literally the day after christmas you're
looking at your tree with disgust
everybody does
or if you have a fake tree you just put
off the hassle of taking it down
for months until you finally get around
to it only because
you don't want people judging you when
they come over for your fourth of july
barbecue
so the whole thing is madness and it
must end we must free ourselves
we must stand up with one voice and
refuse to be enslaved to this lunacy
it's gone on for too long it ends today
christmas trees are canceled once and
for all
and that's going to do it for me my wife
wants to go get a christmas treat today
so we're going to go do that
speaking of not practicing what you
preach well i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the matt wall show if you did go
ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content